[Music]
which couple has the most shocking scene
in finale shocking is innocent yeah
who has changed the most after the one
year time jump in the finale
Toby what about Jason well he's not
gonna be in the finale and there are a
couple actors that we really tried to
get but they were you know they're
booked on other shows and legally they
can't come back to us so he's one of
those but but somebody we tried all
season to get get back who is in the
finale and on another show is Melissa
Torrey DeVitto so we were really excited
about that
how will Melissa's return affect the
Hastings and the DiLaurentis is dynamic
well you'll just have to wait we have
been saying we're gonna ask you this all
season if the Rosewood run down to the
moms get out of the basement you happy
wait till next week yeah it's just well
it's not shown okay it's discuss it's
discussed maybe not completely in the
way you want but it has discuss any
other major returns that you can talk
about maybe some parents that we haven't
seen or siblings that we haven't seen in
a while some of the moms are back okay
right the ones that are still alive okay
wait does that mean Holly Marie Combs is
back yeah yeah yeah yeah someone were to
be so ambitious mark and we watch like
it all we watch the whole series before
the finale is there a certain episode in
particular maybe one that's early on
you're like maybe pay attention to this
one it's all of the these last 10
episodes we've talked a lot of Easter
eggs intentionally and to them because
we wanted fans to have a really good
chance to to figure this out and be well
yeah you literally if you watch the last
time you like oh my gosh that makes so
much more sense there it's fun I want to
show that the fans understand that like
this ad well everybody is in a woven
yeah but but as one story ends and other
began so with with the the reveal of
Mona then began the Charlotte's Dorian
and with the reveal of Charlotte becomes
this ad so this ad is separate in terms
of playing the game from those other a
always nothing like game notice though
going back to like season one or two
correct
Janelle said when she was here that
brother reveal it's a little bit of
everything at once like we're finding
out as the girls are finding out it's
not so much a reveal can you guys
explain a little bit of how that happens
I get how everything unfolds
yeah but sometimes it's also the viewers
will know before the girls do which is
always fun just a little bit this is why
we want it to be two hours long because
we didn't want to leave fans with a lot
of questions so the reveal is very
important but then the understanding of
it is equally as important so that's why
it's two hours so both the fans and the
pre lawyers can all process it all at
the same time well speaking of that
Sasha take us back to the time when you
were processing who ad was Mar would you
tell her like what was this conversation
Ike
she didn't yeah I was I was sneaky about
it I was asking all the right questions
to the right person
Oh who is she why are we asking them to
I mean I don't know I don't know anymore
than you so I found out like little bits
and pieces and I was trying to piece it
together and so does the person who is
ad asked me not to tell anyone because
that person didn't want to affect
certain scenes in certain ways but I was
like I've never said anything like when
you found out how what kind of went
through your mind so that's really how
did you tell this person who is going to
be ad that they were going to be ad was
that a separate conversation a good one
yes that was a separate conversation
that I had just with that person fairly
early on when when the decision was made
that that would be ad because it
affected a lot of that person how would
you describe the very last scene of the
series in one word it's that full circle
it's a full circle moment yes yes yes
yeah a bonus full circle moment yeah
that I think they always leave that like
tag after yeah yeah um it's sort of that
although this show ends the world
content it was one of my favorites what
was your reaction when you read the
final scene um I I'm so glad that you
put it in there because it they didn't
like necessarily shock me but it was
epic and I was like that is amazing yeah
there's some summary of our show in a
way it was like that is so pol and was
that your own goal when you were writing
it Mar to make it a full circle moment
yeah just to know that the mythology of
this town will always go on it's not
going to end with with the end of your
life what are the chances that you could
get an MSN spin-off for Pretty Little
Liars well I mean everything is possible
and anything is possible people think
that your new series the perfectionist
could tie in somehow with a Pretty
Little Liars spin-off can you speak to
that no oh so it could be in the same
kind of universe could be the same
universe or or feel like a similar
universe mm-hmm would any of the
characters like Ali that in psychopathy
I could be okay I would love to be
honest about everything but yeah surely
been helping in the next couple weeks we
can talk about more about that I saw
Sarah laughs last week and we loved
working together so hopefully we can get
to
too much anymore things too
[Music]
you